look man um obviously the the so can you
kind of break down because I don't think
a lot of people understand a lot of the
business model when it comes to
the weed game I think a lot of people
think it's like like we're talking off
off the air it's like
you get in the weed game and you just
print money which is not the case so
many companies they they they're they're
here for six months they're here for two
years and then they're gone like you
said you you're 12 years in for you guys
are you guys
strictly distro wholesale
um you guys don't have a dispensary
license do you yeah so my my company got
a bunch of layers to it you know what
I'm saying um a lot of markets yeah we
had a bunch of markets we're in I think
we're in like 10 markets total
um in a variation of different like ways
right so uh for the viola brand you know
we have uh cultivated or operated in
California Oregon Michigan and Colorado
um to your point now the entry has
changed so much
um I think the asset light uh approach
which means to what you said focusing on
wholesaling focusing more on just The
Branding
um you know the sell through and
different things like that is probably
the way to go if you're trying to scale
a brand almost like the kind of cookies
model yeah um but even that's difficult
because then you got to have a hell of a
procurement team and make sure like the
quality control is Right quality control
is the main thing right it's everything
right but you know so either way it's
very difficult both ways right
um we also have started opening up some
retail locations through a like sister
company that we have called Village
um you know so Viola owns a percentage
of village and all of the Village
locations are named Viola so we have so
you guys do have sore fronts so yeah so
we have two uh we have two in Missouri
okay we have two in Illinois about to
open up we have one in Jersey we're
about to open we're about to open one up
in Maryland uh you know we hope to get
something going down in Florida
um and then also New York we're working
on New York currently is it crazy for
you to go to New York as a kid from the
east coast and see how open the week
like have you been in New York City
recently of course it is like
the craziest [__] I've ever seen it's
like like people think like it's Federal
legalization people think like
California is like everyone's out here
smoking weed now you go to New York and
you're just walking in the park and
there's a bunch of dudes with fold up
tables selling drugs it's crazy near
cops or you go to the store to buy a
juice and a sandwich and the guy behind
the back he's got all kind of weed and
shrooms and [__] it's [__] wild yeah
New York and it happens New York is
definitely the Wild Wild West they
decriminalized and everybody just is
NYPD just don't care they're just like
hey dude at the end of the day which is
good it's prohibition it's great yeah
sometimes you gotta you gotta take
advantage it's just wildness either like
contrast yeah it's crazy you know to
your point like I remember there was a
point you like you said you you know you
rode through the city I mean one time I
had got some weed in New York and I was
still playing but it's the summertime
yeah and I got pulled over and I just
picked up a couple ounces from somebody
and it would have my whole car stinking
and I was so scared yeah and the cop
took my stuff and everything and you
know I told him it's a new truck that's
why the plate was wrong whatever and he
literally my license and insurance back
and was like stop smoking in the car I
hadn't even smoked I was just you know
what I'm saying but he could have
literally locked me up for it yeah you
know what I'm saying to like to your
point now I could be blazing he pulled
me over like what's up you want to hit
this
you know what I'm saying so it's
definitely changed a lot and you know I
think that the New York program on the
legal side is probably going to be one
of the best in the industry I think
because of the way that they are trying
to make sure that
um Legacy
um people that were disproportionately
affected by the war on drugs are like
winners and that are participating in
the beginning and not in the you know
later like most States because most
States they give all these big companies
these opportunities and they say okay
now we're going to let you know the
people that you know the poor people get
in and I always say like I used a
comparison is like playing against the
Warriors and spotting them 20 30 points
and then saying go out and play
literally what happened yeah you know
what I'm saying so with New York they're
doing it you know totally they're doing
it the right way they're rolling it out
properly and um I'm excited for the New
York Market I think it's going to be
probably the biggest in the country
um what were did you ever have to dodge
piss tests
no in the NBA no I didn't I didn't smoke
until like I told you that one time and
then my last year in the league
um I was just using more CBD and stuff
like that I always wanted to keep my my
record clean just in case because you
know they say they don't keep tabs on
all that stuff but they do you know what
I'm saying and then you get like a
stigma on you that's like kind of unfair
because then they talk about it on a
sports center it's like who cares it's
weeds like you know and especially now
is now okay and then you know they
allowed it in the bubble out of nowhere
right you had one of your facilities be
legally rated in Detroit right correct
so what can you give me a breakdown what
happened there yeah so pretty much
um you know and how long ago was this
this was I think six years ago now but
what happens is like in all these states
you know you go through this whole
process right and at the end of the day
unfortunately it's still like regular
state workers that are responsible for a
lot of the information and all that kind
of stuff and like even when I apply for
licenses like bro I'm literally giving
everybody every bank account every lease
every this every day like all these
different states these people have all
my information bro yeah yeah that's all
I'm saying so you go through that whole
process and you know you get these
permits you get all these different
things to operate and you know certain
things happen so what happened for us
was you know someone jumps off the
bridge our facility is right next to the
uh Ambassador Bridge that goes from
Detroit into Windsor Canada uh they're
looking for the body allegedly the Coast
Guard comes past our building they smell
weed they call the city or the police
the police call the city the lady at the
city who's in charge is on vacation so
they talk to like her assistant who
doesn't know the [__] going on there's
no looks at the paperwork oh I had I
don't have that address anywhere on any
files
the gang unit exercises a a warrant on
the building the gang unit the gang unit
they come in they dress regular so I'm
at home my aunt calls me and she says I
think we're getting robbed I look on the
camera and everybody got on regular
clothes bro so I'm like oh [__] y'all so
I'm like you know you know the procedure
go Lock It Go lock yourself in the back
right
um I'm looking on the camera she's still
looking on the camera because the
camera's in that back room then we see a
Paddy Wagon that comes by that says
Detroit police so I'm like oh Auntie is
the police cool you got all the
paperwork just go open the door at this
point they're Ram in the door she opens
the door before they have to bust it
down and she's trying to give them the
paperwork and all I see on the camera is
just an AR go to her face in the
paperwork form or whatever so they back
her into the door and they all running
through the door they ramming the other
door down and the other end just still
ramming RAM and ramming and then like
literally three minutes later the
cameras is cut
so now I can't see anything oh so now
I'm nervous as hell you know thinking
like what happened like you know I'm
still me right I don't want to go to
jail right you know you understand what
I'm saying and long story short man it
was just some Mix-Ups at the city level
um and you know they had to let
everybody out did they uh pay for any of
that did they damage your [__] they
damaged all of our [__] they took all of
our equipment what they did was they put
us on the news that night with our
address
4473 West Jefferson Avenue and they left
the warehouse open
so allegedly someone comes in there with
equipment that know how to take down
lights and know how to take HVAC off the
roof and they just completely wiped us
out over two days because it took me two
days to get there
you know what I'm saying by the time I
got there my warehouse was empty
well you know they say this about
Detroit they will got a [__] a house
out there they'll take the copper out
that [__] they'll take Detroit
is known for that [__] like if you got a
house in Detroit and it's not occupied
good luck bro you need but just get all
my [__] like you needed ladders you
needed like oh it was probably the
police it was probably like one of the
cops cousins okay bro they got us bro so
it's probably so whoever out there got
our equipment we started your growing
all that y'all can send us a little
thank you or something man because you
know they got state of the art equipment
bro it was like all the equipment were
you able to sue we're in the Pro we're
in a lawsuit still after all this time
Jesus and still you know they have like
this immunity because they're police
it's just it's all bad bro yeah
um how much uh frustration do you have
dealing with weird
listen man the marijuana industry is
full of a lot of weirdos yes sir very
much guys not of the culture guys who've
never were involved in weed in their
life corporate dudes I mean I've dealt
with it a lot where I'm just like these
are the [__] weenies that are making
decisions that some of these companies
and then that's when you see like
certain like Brands like fall like fall
off or even like dispensary brands that
are like really big Brands but it's like
a bunch of weirdo like you know uh VC
guys running them like like for you
being a guy who you know obviously cares
about a plant cares so much about this
like the benefits of weed and just the
culture and all that [__] like is it
well frustrating dealing with some of
the weird [__] that you have to deal
with because I talked to burner about
the [__] all the time burner deals with
a lot of weirdos yeah yeah it's very
frustrating but it's just part of the
business bro like you know we're still
pioneering the industry and to your
point there's a lot of people that's
going to come and go yeah you know what
I'm saying but you gotta it's all gonna
weed itself out and you just got to be a
part of the process you know what I'm
saying so yeah I'd be frustrated but not
that frustrated you know what I'm saying
I've kind of gotten used to it you know
I think that once again also because of
my background being of course yeah yeah
for sure bro you're a pro I'm a pro
exactly so for me I guess it doesn't
bother me as much but to your point yes
um there's a lot of weird [__] going on
in the industry a lot of weird people in
it
um and like I said bro we'll see how
long it takes to wean it all out but
it's gonna be a while
um how many shelves you guys on
um we're in California yeah yeah in Cali
in Cali so we've we've went to approach
like small batch product or whatever so
we're in probably about 25 stores okay
yeah what's the biggest market for viola
uh right now it's Michigan Michigan's
booming yeah Michigan and then I would
say second is Florida oh yeah we did a
partnership with a company called
flowery that's booming dope and then I
so what I like about what you're doing
is like introducing new strains new
Partnerships
um
have you because because I I know you uh
had did berner's Roundtable no I haven't
done or you guys you guys did an
interview or something that uh no I
haven't done his set it's on YouTube I
watched it me and Berner yeah
did I maybe I did I mean I smoked that
much it's just like it was probably like
five years ago four or five years ago I
did an interview with burn a notch
I don't know if it was an interview it
was you guys chopping it up I've done
I've done some like Zoom stuff with him
maybe I'm am I tripping hold on let me
see
because I swear to God I thought I saw
this I thought you were sitting oh I
know what are you talking about I did at
uh right here interviews Al Harrington
oh yeah that was way back in the day
you're right we did that right here on
Sunset you're right I know I'm not crazy
on Sunset you're right I forgot I forgot
I was gonna say like um have you got any
advice from a guy like burn in terms of
like he's done such a good job of like
building out like the franchise model on
the on the um
you know on the dispensary side and then
obviously introducing your strains
constantly that's why I thought it was
Dopey to the Iverson [__] because I was
like oh that makes sense you know yeah
nah yeah um yeah we talk all the time
every time we see each other like the
last time I saw him um well I saw him
when he did the Erica Badu thing here in
Cali but before that where we actually
got a chance to sit in the trailer and
talk for about an hour was down in
Atlanta for the Revolt conference but
yeah so he's always just you know giving
me his perspective what's going on and
you know the one thing that I would say
like is consistent every time we talk is
all about the quality of the week always
you know what I'm saying like you find
good weed make a cool bag of the cell
yeah you know what I'm saying and like
kind of keep it simple stupid kind of
vibe 100 so
um you know big shout out to burn the
big guy shot big shout out to what he's
done he's definitely you know
well listen whatever wherever you're at
well not wherever you're at but if
this [__] is I smell the irishness guess
shout out to Viola
um I appreciate you pulling up man and
talking and uh thanks for having me
congrats on the 12 12 years yeah 12
years in this [__] yeah man hey so go
support and then for people who don't
know like uh what's the Instagram where
can people kind of find out more check
out uh yeah uh Instagram is at Viola
um you know we also have some other tags
outside of that but go to that Viola
first he'll get you there uh
violabrands.com is the website and if
you want to get some of this cool ass
fire yeah I got a real merch yeah go to
violagoods.com we got a bunch of new
[__] dropping over the next couple weeks
we got sneakers we did a collab with
cool car we're doing a collab with uh
Lambo King on some merch on some
T-shirts and hoodies you know what I'm
saying so go check it out bro boom my
guy Al Harrington appreciate you pulling
up yes sir thank you all right we have
to make it happen yes sir boom